So have you ever really stopped
to think about this?
That the very technologies we
use everyday, the ones designed
to, you know, connect us, might
actually be controlling us,
Maybe subtly, maybe not so
subtly.
It's a really unsettling
thought, isn't it?
It is.
And then what if these systems
of control, the ones developing
in places we think of as totally
different, like the US and
China, what if they're actually
becoming more alike than we
imagine?
Yeah, that's a really
provocative question.
We tend to put things in neat
boxes, right?
US versus them, free versus
unfree.
It's comfortable.
Exactly.
But the reality, especially with
digital power and surveillance,
well, it seems to be way more
complex.
And the material we're diving
into today argues they're
converging in some pretty
surprising and maybe
uncomfortable ways.
Absolutely.
And that's what we're tackling
today.
We're doing a deep dive into
this really fascinating, maybe
even a bit disturbing piece of
material called Two Sides of the
Same Coin when Silicon Valley
and the CCP start speaking the
same language.
And this isn't just some dry
academic paper, right?
It makes a really bold claim.
It challenges our basic
assumptions about surveillance,
about power, and honestly, about
what freedom even means anymore
in this digital world.
Right, so our mission for this
deep dive is to really pull out
the key insights from this text.
We're going to unpack its main
argument, which is pretty
startling.
But just.
And that the world's two biggest
powers, the US and China, are
maybe without even fully
intending it, sometimes building
these mirrored surveillance
societies.
Yeah, we'll look at the
mechanisms they're using, the
motivations behind it all, and
some, you know, really
unexpected similarities, the
material points out.
OK, but crucially, we're not
just stopping there because like
you said, things aren't always
neat boxes.
To really get it, you need the
whole picture.
Exactly.
So we'll also dig into the
counterpoints, the critical
analysis that's actually in the
source material itself.
It pushes back on its own
claims.
That's good, so we get the full
nuance view.
The goal is to help you
listening in get really well
informed on this because it's
super important, but without
feeling totally overwhelmed by
it.
All yeah, it's dense stuff, but
vital.
And what's compelling about this
source is that dual approach.
First, it hits you with the
strong, almost unsettling
argument about the similarities
in digital control between the
US and China.
Right, the convergence idea.
But then it doesn't just leave
you hanging there.
It pivots.
It offers this really rigorous
critique of its own arguments,
gives you counterpoints, fact
checks, brings in broader
context.
It kind of tempers the drama.
A bit, so it forces you to think
critically, not just accept the
first argument.
Precisely.
It's a balanced way to tackle a
really charged topic.
OK, let's peel back that first
layer, then Section 1, the core
argument, this idea of two sides
of the same digital coin.
Right.
And it kicks off with a really
bold statement.
It says both the US and China
are building these quote
surveillance societies, and not
just in a vague sense.
It claims they're often using
the quote same machinery, think
data, algorithms and this
relentless drive to know, to
score and ultimately to shape
what citizens do and think.
Same machinery.
That's a strong claim.
It is, and what really jumps out
is the core distinction it
makes, or rather, the
distinction it minimizes.
It argues the main difference
isn't in the technology or the
goal, but primarily in, quote,
the branding and the story we
tell ourselves.
Wow.
So how we justify it?
Basically, yeah.
This immediately clashes with
how we usually think, right?
We see the US and China as
fundamentally different on this.
China surveils, the US values
privacy.
Or so the story.
Goes right, That's the standard
narrative.
But this material says maybe
that distinction is getting
blurry, superficial.
Exactly.
It pushes us to ask why this
convergence might be happening
now.
It's not just about the tech
being available, though that's
part of it.
What else?
It points to a mix of tech
maturity.
We can do this pervasive
surveillance now and really
importantly, some big
ideological shifts, especially
happening within the US.
So the tools are ready and
certain powerful people are
thinking, hey, we can and maybe
should use these tools for
control.
That seems to be the implication
which brings us right to a
really central figure in this
whole argument, Peter Teal.
Teal OK billionaire investor.
PayPal Co founder.
Yes, but the material introduces
him as much more than that.
It calls him, quote, the
intellectual godfather of the
New Right.
That signal his influence goes
way beyond just tech and
finance.
He's painted as a real thought
leader.
A philosopher king for a new
era, as the material puts it
somewhere.
That sounds pretty dramatic.
It does, and his philosophy is
apparently key here.
His skepticism about democracy.
His belief in hierarchy, his
fascination with, quote, the
management of human desire.
Managing desire?
What does that even mean in this
context?
Well, it seems tied to this idea
that he sees technology not just
as a business tool, but as a way
to shape society itself, to
impose a certain kind of order
based on hierarchy.
It's about fundamentally
structuring power.
OK, so how does that translate
into actual influence?
Is it just ideas or is there
more?
Oh, it's tangible.
According to this analysis, the
material says Thiel has quote
seeded a generation of
politicians, tech entrepreneurs
and policy architects, people
who share or have adopted parts
of his worldview.
Examples.
Well, his early crucial support
for Donald Trump is 1 big one
funding anti woke candidates and
really relevant here, his
investments in companies that
are basically the plumbing of
America's surveillance capacity.
Palantir, Facebook.
Right Palantir.
Especially data analysis for
government defense.
Exactly so.
The material positions Teal as
this crucial bridge, a bridge
between Silicon Valley's biggest
players, the monopolists, and
the populist right.
He connects.
Quote memes, money and power.
So it's not just investing cash,
it's linking ideology,
communication strategies and the
tech platform platforms
themselves.
Precisely translating philosophy
into tech and politics.
OK.
And this ties into that
management of desire thing.
How does someone like Teal, this
philosopher king type use tech
to control what the material
calls the chaotic masses?
This is where it gets really
interesting and maybe a bit
dark.
The material points to Teal's
interest in Renee Gerard's
concept of memetic desire.
Memetic desire, remind me.
The idea that we don't really
know what we want intrinsically,
we copy our desires from others.
This can lead to rivalry,
conflict, social chaos as
desires clash and escalate.
OK, now Teal, according to this
analysis, sees this potential
for chaos not just as
inevitable, but maybe even
desirable, or at least useful.
Useful.
How could chaos be useful?
If you believe you're one of the
few who can manage it, if you
see it as a force that can be
channelled to break down old
structures and impose a new
hierarchical order, perhaps led
by the CEO kings, the material
mentions It's a very strategic,
almost manipulative view of
social dynamics.
Wow, OK, that's a heavy concept.
Managing chaos through tech and
surveillance.
Which brings us to how this
plays out in practice.
Section 2.
Unpacking the parallel
surveillance in practice.
Right.
And the first point is how
surveillance has become like the
material says, the water we swim
in.
It used to feel like something
distant, right?
Something the CCP did to its
citizens.
Exactly.
That was the narrative.
But the argument here is that
the same kinds of tech, the same
methods are now tracking
American gig workers,
protesters, immigrants,
minorities.
And this expanded dramatically
when.
The material points,
particularly to the period since
2016, surveillance, moving
beyond just borders, going deep
into cities, into our online
lives.
How specifically?
What are the examples?
Well, it talks about agencies
like ICE and DHS and it mentions
this thing called the Mimetic
Engineering complex.
Mimetic engineering complex.
What's that?
It's defined broadly, not just
Meta X, Google, Amazon, Open AI,
but also talk radio, the whole
advertising PR world, basically
the entire ecosystem that shapes
information and attention.
OK, so this complex, what did
ICE and DHS do with it?
They systematically scraped
social media looking for risky
posts, using algorithms to flag
individuals based on their
online words and connections.
And who were they targeting?
Just immigrants.
No, and that's a crucial point.
The material stresses It wasn't
just non citizens.
It included U.S. citizens with
immigrant backgrounds and even
people holding what the
government deemed dangerous
beliefs, views that went against
administration policy.
So, ideological screening using
social media.
That's the implication.
The analysis points to Trump era
executive orders that gave DHS
huge latitude to use publicly
available information, tweets,
Facebook posts, even private
messages if they got warrants to
build deportation cases.
And the impact?
An immediate chilling effect,
especially in immigrant
communities.
People got scared.
They started self censoring,
deleting accounts.
Warnings spread like wildfire.
Yeah, anything you say online
can and will be used against
you.
It sounds like the machinery
started producing similar
effects regardless of the flag.
Fear self censorship.
That's exactly the parallel
being drawn.
OK, so it's not just tracking
actions, but potentially
thoughts or expressed beliefs.
It's thought police.
Right, the material argues.
This mimetic engineering complex
isn't just selling ads anymore,
quote.
They sell influence.
Influence over what we buy or
more.
More influence over what we
think, how we feel.
The algorithms, it says, are
designed to maximize engagement.
And how do they do that often?
Outrage.
Conflict.
By amplifying outrage, envy, and
tribalism.
That's the quote.
It's an attention economy fueled
by strong emotions.
You see it in your own feed,
right?
The stuff that gets you riled
up.
Yeah, absolutely.
And the scary part, the material
argues, is that since 2016
especially, these platforms
became tools not just for fun or
commerce, but for state and mob
enforcement of ideological
conformity.
State and mob.
How does that?
Work well, think about it,
depending on the year and the
political wins, people posting
certain views, anti vax, anti
lockdown, pro Palestinian, anti
trump.
They didn't just get argued
with, they faced doxing online
harassment mobs.
And sometimes actual official
consequences.
Yeah, targeting by ICE or local
police investigating them based
on online activity.
It shows how the platforms
become spaces where conformity
is enforced both informally by
crowds and formerly by
authorities.
That reminds me of that Rand
Paul quote you mentioned is in
the material.
Exactly.
It fits perfectly here.
When you have a government that
can collect massive amounts of
information, that data becomes a
powerful instrument for control.
It doesn't have to be used for
heavy-handed prosecutions.
The mere existence of it creates
a Society of caution, suspicion
and conformity.
The mere existence of the data
changes society.
Wow, it creates that chilling
effect, that sense of being
watched, which leads to self
censorship.
And this goes beyond just
individuals expressing views
online.
What about organized groups like
protesters?
Yes, the material talks about
predictive policing in this
context, using platform and data
not just after the fact but
before protests to monitor
discussions and flag potential
agitators.
Predicting trouble.
Essentially, and in some cases,
cities actually partnered with
tech firms to map out networks
of influence among activists,
identifying key people,
potential flashpoints.
Mapping activist networks.
The material describes it
starkly, an approach straight
out of the CCP's playbook for
dissent control, again drawing
that direct, unsettling parallel
in methodology.
OK, so the methods start to look
similar.
What about the relationship
between the state and the tech
companies themselves?
That seems like a key difference
usually.
Right.
And the material tackles this
head on with the idea of state
corporate fusion, calling it the
new Leviathan.
Sounds ominous, yeah.
How does it compare the US and
China here?
In China, it's pretty
straightforward, right?
The CCP basically compels tech
companies to hand over data.
Share everything with the state
top down command.
OK, that's clear
authoritarianism.
But in the US, the approach is
different, maybe more subtle.
The state doesn't usually compel
in the same way.
Instead, it quote, contracts out
its surveillance.
Pays companies for the data.
Exactly.
Huge government contracts for
data access, Algorithmic
analysis, Predictive tools.
But the material argues the
effect is largely the same.
How so?
Because it results in a quote,
seamless flow of data from your
phone, your bank, your face,
into the hands of power.
Whether compelled or contracted,
the data ends up in the same
place.
And this public private
partnership is presented as the
new norm.
The new bipartisan ideology,
according to the text.
It's just how things are done
now, regardless of who's in
charge.
It's less about if the state
gets the data, more about the
mechanism and the payment
involved.
And Teal's role comes back here,
his investments in Palantir
Facebook.
The material argues these aren't
contradictions to this
philosophy, but logical
extensions of it.
Belief in monopoly hierarchy,
Managing memetic desire.
Maybe Chaos is fine if you have
the tools to manage it.
Tools provided by companies like
Palantir.
So he invests in the tools to
manage the chaos he potentially
sees as inevitable or even
useful.
That's the interpretation
offered.
It paints a picture of him
seeing these tech platforms not
just as businesses, but as
instruments for shaping society
according to his hierarchical
vision.
And what about the political
angle?
Politicians who criticize Big
Tech publicly.
Like Trump and his circle
railing against liberal Silicon
Valley?
Yeah, the material suggests that
even while they criticize
publicly, they privately see
these very tools, the data, the
algorithms, as essential means
to achieve their goals,
restoring order, achieving
greatness.
So criticize the power
structure, but uses tools
anyway.
A strategic embrace, perhaps A
bit cynical.
Maybe like that Josh Hawley
quote in the material about
fighting the robber barons of
Big Tech to recover America's
populist democracy.
Right, I remember that.
He's voicing a real concern, but
the underlying theme across the
political spectrum often
involves wanting to control or
shape the information flow, even
if the justification is
different.
OK, the material then focuses on
a really specific and disturbing
parallel targeting immigrants
and minorities.
It calls it a universal
playbook.
Yeah, it starts with a known
example, the CCP's use of
surveillance against Eagers and
dissidents.
That's the established benchmark
for this kind of targeted
control.
But then it applies it to the
US.
Directly, it highlights how
under Trump, ICE used social
media monitoring and predictive
analytics, specifically against
immigrants and even U.S.
citizens with immigrant family
backgrounds.
Based on what their posts, who
they do online, both.
Building cases.
Identifying perceived risks
within specific communities
based on identity associations.
Online speech.
The material mentions anecdotal
reports from that time.
Of people being detained or
deported based on old tweets,
Facebook friends.
Exactly.
Things like that.
And the core logic the material
claims is disturbingly the same.
Identify, isolate, neutralize.
Wow.
The argument is the only real
difference lies in the mechanics
and branding, not the
fundamental goal of controlling
a specific population group
deemed problematic.
That branding difference, yeah,
it comes up again with the
language used, right?
The philosophical rhetoric.
Yeah, absolutely.
The CCP talks about harmony,
stability, national
rejuvenation, words that sound
positive, collective.
While the US right like Trump or
Thiel talks about order
security, American greatness
also sounds positive but maybe
more nationalist or security
focused.
Right.
But the material argues both
sets of terms are essentially
code for control, code for
managing risk, for channeling
that potentially chaotic mimetic
desire away from the powerful
and towards acceptable targets.
Immigrants.
Dissidents.
Political opponents.
So different words, same
underlying goal.
Keep power, suppress threats,
manage the masses from the top
down.
That's the core assertion, and
it ties back to Thiel's
skepticism about democracy.
His comments like competition is
for losers.
We're questioning if freedom and
democracy are compatible.
How does that mirror the CCP?
The material says it mirrors the
CCP fundamental distrust of
pluralism, of dissent, of messy
democratic processes.
It suggests both share a core
belief the crowd is dangerous,
the individual as a potential
threat and the solution as
hierarchy, surveillance and the
management of desire.
A very similar worldview
operating under different
political labels.
It really brings that Harry
Truman quote from the material
into focus, doesn't it?
About governments committed to
silencing opposition, only
having one way to go.
Down the path of increasingly
repressive measures until it
becomes a source of terror and
creates a country where everyone
lives in fear.
Yeah, that hits hard in this
context.
And this leads to the point
about denial and camouflage the
American way.
How so?
The material observes that the
CCP is, in a way, more honest
about its authoritarianism.
They don't really pretend it's
something else.
Right, it's overt.
Whereas the US administration,
particularly the one focused on
in this section, tends to cloak
it in the language of law and
order and securing our borders.
Using familiar acceptable terms
to justify the same fundamental
approach.
Slightly different wrapping.
As the material puts it, it's
about making control palatable
within a democratic narrative.
A key difference in
presentation, if not always an
underlying technique.
So where does this convergence
potentially lead?
What's the end game according to
this argument?
An unsettling one?
No place to hide It paints a
picture of a world where the
actual infrastructure of control
is global, modular and for sale
to the highest bidder.
Meaning the tech developed in
one place can be easily sold and
used anywhere.
That's the fear a universally
available toolkit for social
management crossing borders
easily.
And in that world, the line
between free and unfree gets.
Blurred by data, the material
concludes that the only real
difference left might just be
who gets to pull the levers.
That's a pretty.
Bleak outlook.
The tools become universal, the
branding fades, and it just
comes down to who's in charge of
the data flow.
It is stark, though, that
Reagan, code included, also
offers a warning, but from a
different angle, doesn't it,
about the threat coming not from
foreign foes but from power
slipping away from the
grassroots to a remote central
authority?
Yeah, a warning about domestic
centralization of power, which
fits the digital surveillance
concern too.
So wrapping up this core
argument, the material suggests
the US and CCP systems aren't
opposites anymore, if they ever
truly were in this digital
realm, they're becoming
reflections, learning from each
other, competing, and maybe
ultimately resembling each
other.
Wow, OK, that is a really
powerful and, like you said,
unsettling argument.
It is, but remember, that's just
one side of the coin, right?
The material itself insists we
look at the other side, the
counterpoints, the critiques.
Right, Section 3.
The other side of the coin,
Counterpoints and critical
analysis.
We need this balance.
Absolutely.
And the first big counterpoint
is basically.
It's not so neat.
Meaning the mirror image idea is
too simple.
Exactly.
It's too neat, maybe overlooks
crucial differences.
The reality is messier.
Like what key differences?
The most fundamental one, the
CCP, is a one party
authoritarian state.
Period.
No Free Press, no independent
courts that can really challenge
the party, no meaningful
elections.
That structure changes
everything about how
surveillance is used and
experienced.
OK, where's in the US?
In the US, even with a growing
surveillance apparatus, there
are still brakes.
Imperfect ones, sure, but they
exist.
Courts can rule against the
government.
Whistleblowers leak things.
Journalists investigate.
There are lawsuits.
There's Congress, messy as it
is.
So mechanisms for pushback and
accountability still exist, even
if they're under pressure.
They do.
They add friction which isn't
really present in the same way
in the CCP system.
What about the methods of
control?
Are they really the same?
The material offers the carrot
versus stick distinction here.
America's version, it argues, is
often about selling the
convenience of being watched.
The give us your data will give
you dopamine model.
Yeah, basically, you trade
privacy for personalized
services, targeted ads, easy
logins, cool features.
There's often an element of
perceived benefit and opt in,
even if the implications aren't
always clear.
Where is the CCP PS approach is?
Much more stick.
Overt social credit scores
affecting your life.
Direct punishment for non
compliance re education camps in
extreme cases.
It's coercion, not convenience.
So similar tech maybe, but the
incentive structure and a lived
experience are totally
different.
Fundamentally different, this
counterpoint argues.
OK, this sounds related to that
other big rebuttal surveillance
capitalism.
The surveillance.
State exactly, drawing on
Shoshanna Zubach's work, the
core ideas about the motive.
Right, in the US, the main
driver is.
Profit.
Overwhelmingly.
It's about profit Algorithm
shape behavior to get you to
click ads, buy products, stay
engaged longer.
It's about monetization, not
necessarily direct ideological
control by the state.
So Meta, Google, Amazon, they
feed on our engagement, our
outrage, sure.
But.
But crucially, they don't answer
to a single party chairman.
Their primary loyalty is to
shareholders, to revenue growth.
It's a commercial logic, not
primarily a political one
dictated by a ruling party.
That creates a very different
dynamic.
They might enable state
surveillance through contracts,
but their core business isn't
the same as the states.
That's the distinction this
rebuttal emphasizes.
OK, what about the fact checking
part?
What did the material confirm is
true and what did it say was
maybe overstated in the main
argument?
It confirms some key things we
discussed.
Yes, ICEA did scrape social
media for risky immigrant posts.
Yes, predictive policing was
used to flag activists.
Yes, Peter Thiel has publicly
questioned democracy.
These are factual.
It was overstated.
The idea of the US system being
same machinery, same result,
that's called 2 pat.
It ignores constitutional limits
even if they're tested and the
real pushback from activists and
courts.
Outcomes aren't identical.
And the no place to hide idea is
also flagged as overstated.
While surveillance is pervasive,
we do have countermeasures.
Encryption is still widely
available and legal.
We have things like GDPR
influencing privacy globally,
FOIA requests, lawsuits, tools
like Signal and Tor.
So there are ways to resist or
create friction.
It's not a totally sealed
system.
Right.
There's still agency, still
tools for pushback.
The material also adds more
complexity, right?
These contextual threads and
tangles.
Yeah, complicating the simple
narratives, For example, Thiel
and Trump, or the GOP more
broadly, it's not a unified
block on surveillance.
You have libertarians opposing
mass surveillance clashing with
populist who might favor it.
For law and order, there's
internal division.
Makes sense and the state versus
corporate dynamic?
It reiterates that difference.
China compels data sharing. the
US contracts it out.
The counterpoint argues the
outcome isn't quite the same
because of that friction.
We mentioned court battles,
leaks, contract negotiations.
It's not as seamless as the main
argument might imply.
OK, and what about big tech
itself?
Is it just a tool for the right
or?
No, and this is important, the
material points out big tech's
inconsistency.
Yes, they sometimes censor
conservatives, but they've also
censored leftists, pro
Palestinian voices, anti vax
people.
It's described less as a
consistent ideological enforcer
and more as a chaos machine.
A.
Chaos machine meaning.
Driven by engagement, ad
revenue, and often clumsy
reactive content moderation
policies rather than a single
coherent political agenda, it
challenges the idea that it's a
simple monolith serving one
side.
It's messier than that.
And the nuance extends to China
too, right?
Avoiding the cartoon villain
trap.
Yes, the counter analysis
cautions against that.
It suggests thinking of the CCP
leadership as strategic, long
term thinkers.
They think in centuries.
They test, adapt, respond to
carrot and stick.
More practical than evil, as the
material puts it.
Not excusing them, but
understanding their approach.
Exactly, understanding their
pragmatism, their realism, their
nationalism.
And it adds that they watch the
US with a mix of fear and
amusement, which adds a layer
beyond just seeing them as a
monolithic threat.
OK, that's a lot of important
nuance.
What about those quick FAQs
mentioned?
Right distilled points feel on
democracy.
Clear skepticism.
Competition is for losers.
US copying China's playbook,
Similar tech, different
incentives, profit versus
absolute control.
Trump expanding surveillance.
Yes, ICEHHS used social media in
new ways and the Biden admin
hasn't reversed.
All of it shows continuity.
And the big one, can we resist?
The answer given is yes.
Privacy tech, strong data laws,
whistleblowers and relentless
pushback all work.
And crucially, encryption is
still legal.
For now, it points to concrete
tools and strategies.
So resistance is possible.
It's not a completely hopeless
situation.
Not according to this analysis,
no.
There are levers we can still
pull.
OK, so taking all that in the
core argument and the
counterpoints, where does that
leave us?
Section 4.
The path forward resistance and
reflection.
Well, the starting point is
accepting A baseline reality.
Surveillance is here to stay.
It's baked into modern life now.
Right, we can't really put that
genie back in the bottle.
Probably not.
So the real question, the
critical fork in the road, isn't
if surveillance exists, but
whether it ultimately imprisons
or empowers.
Imprisons or empowers?
Meaning, does it just lock us
into hierarchies and control?
Or can we somehow harness it?
Can data be used to build a
freer future if we keep dragging
it into the light?
Can we make it work for
transparency, accountability,
individual agency instead of
just top down control?
That's a huge question.
Can we turn a tool of control
into a tool for freedom?
It's about agency, isn't it?
Can we collectively shape how
these powerful tools are used,
ensure they serve us, rather
than just observe and manage us?
And the material ends with that
metaphor, right?
The coin, yeah.
The coin doesn't just have two
sides, it spins.
Meaning it's not a fixed state,
it's dynamic, always changing.
Exactly.
It's not US versus China as
static opposites or surveillance
versus freedom as a done deal.
It's an ongoing process.
Control and influence are
constantly shifting, adapting.
The situation is.
Fluid, which means we need to
stay vigilant, keep questioning.
It's a call to active
engagement.
Definitely challenge the
narratives, demand
accountability.
The tech itself might be
neutral, but how it's used, the
context, the intent, that's what
matters for freedom and power.
OK, wow, we have covered a lot
today.
A really deep dive into these
parallels, often unsettling
ones, between US and Chinese
surveillance explored feels
influence.
But also, importantly, consider
those crucial counterpoints that
add the nuance we need.
It's definitely a lot to chew
on, but understanding these
convergences, the differences in
motivation, the shared tools, it
feels essential for figuring out
where we're headed.
You know this stuff impacts your
life every single day.
Absolutely.
So the big question for you
listening in What does this all
mean for you?
In this world of constant data
collection, how much control do
you feel you have?
Maybe more importantly, how can
you help ensure these tools
serve freedom, not diminish it?
Can we really imagine that
future?
The material asks about where
data empowers rather than
imprisons?
What would that even look like?
This deep dive, really, it's
just scratching the surface.
It's the start of understanding
these huge shifts in power and
tech.
What stood out most to you
today?
What are you going to do with
this information, this
perspective?
Keep digging, keep asking
questions.
And keep challenging the stories
we tell ourselves about freedom,
power, tech.
Because, like the material says,
that coin is spinning, and
understanding which way it's
turning, well, that feels more
important than ever.